[Music]
earthquakes have always been a
terrifying phenomenon and they've become
more deadly as our cities have grown
with collapsing buildings posing one of
the largest risks
why do buildings collapse in an
earthquake and how can it be prevented
if you've watched a lot of disaster
films you might have the idea that
building collapse is caused directly by
the ground beneath them shaking
violently or even splitting apart but
that's not really how it works
for one thing most buildings are not
located right on a fault line and the
shifting tectonic plates go much deeper
than building foundations so what's
actually going on in fact the reality of
earthquakes and their effect on
buildings is a bit more complicated to
make sense of it
architects and engineers use models like
a two dimensional array of lines
representing columns and beams or a
single line lollipop with circles
representing the building's mass even
when simplified to this degree these
models can be quite useful as predicting
a building's response to an earthquake
is primarily a matter of physics most
collapses that occur during earthquakes
aren't actually caused by the earthquake
itself instead when the ground moves
beneath a building it displaces the
foundation and lower levels sending
shockwaves through the rest of the
structure and causing it to vibrate back
and forth the strength of this
oscillation depends on two main factors
the building's mass which is
concentrated at the bottom and its
stiffness which is the force required to
cause a certain amount of displacement
along with the building's material type
and the shape of its columns stiffness
is largely a matter of height shorter
buildings tend to be stiffer and shift
less while taller buildings are more
flexible you might think that the
solution is to build shorter buildings
so that they shift as little as possible
but the 1985 Mexico City earthquake is a
good example of why that's not the case
during the quake many buildings between
6 and 15 stories tall collapsed what's
strange is that while shorter buildings
nearby
did keep standing building
taller than 15 stories were also less
damaged and the mid-sized buildings that
collapsed were observed shaking far more
violently than the earthquake itself how
is that possible the answer has to do
with something known as a natural
frequency in an oscillating system the
frequency is how many back-and-forth
movement cycles occur within a second
this is the inverse of the period which
is how many seconds it takes to complete
one cycle in a building's natural
frequency determined by its mass and
stiffness is the frequency that its
vibrations will tend to cluster around
increasing a building's mass slows down
the rate at which it naturally vibrates
while increasing stiffness makes it
vibrate faster so in the equation
representing their relationship
stiffness and natural frequency are
proportional to one another while mass
and natural frequency are inversely
proportional what happened in Mexico
City was an effect called resonance
where the frequency of the earthquake
seismic waves happen to match the
natural frequency of the mid sized
buildings like a well-timed push on a
swing set each additional seismic wave
amplified the building's vibration in
its current direction causing it to
swing even further back and so on
eventually reaching a far greater extent
than the initial displacement today
engineers work with geologists and
seismologists to predict the frequency
of earthquake motions at building sites
in order to prevent resonance induced
collapses taking into account factors
such as soil type and fault type as well
as data from previous quakes low
frequencies of motion will cause more
damage to taller and more flexible
buildings while high frequencies of
motion pose more threat to structures
that are shorter and stiffer Engineers
have also devised ways to absorb shocks
and limit deformation using innovative
systems base isolation uses flexible
layers to isolate the foundations
displacement from the rest of the
building while tuned mass damper systems
cancel out resonance by oscillating out
of phase with the natural frequency to
reduce vibrations in the end it's not
the sturdiest buildings
that will remain standing but the
smartest ones
[Music]